foreign
welcome to the show
yeah thanks for having me I appreciate
it absolutely what's going on
well my wife and I were both 45 years
old and we will be completely out of
debt about three years mortgage and
house and everything awesome that's
great we're excited about that my wife
will be taking over her parents uh
catering business probably in the next
three or four years and just kind of
having a hard time figuring out
kind of that Finance how we're going to
do that that type of thing so just kind
of wanted to get your guys's input
um they've kind of basically have said
that they want her to kind of run it and
then kind of split the profit 50 50.
um
and I don't think they've really planned
much for retirement I'm not sure if
that's
necessarily the best way to do it you
know we want them to have a good
retirement we want them to enjoy
retirement but it kind of feels like
it's going to be you know pretty big
burden on my wife and a strain on the
business we would rather not you know
um have to take out a loan to buy the
business
you know that type of thing so they're
saying hey instead of you buying the
business from us and giving us money we
can do this where we get a certain
percentage of the profit over a certain
period of time
well the the period of time is kind of
the I mean they're kind of they want it
forever that's the retirement plan
that's pretty much yeah I'm not taking
that deal
yeah what happens if they live 35 more
years
that's what yeah that's what I asked too
we need to see could be on paper it
could be retirement and
and we could when we retire at 65.
and still have to work to fund their
retirement yeah you said seems like
several times have you all actually sat
down with them and had a very clear
conversation about the numbers where
you've actually seen the numbers and had
clear expectations laid out
now we've tried we did this about a year
ago they're very secretive about how
much they make how much that this
business that's always good taking over
the business from people who won't tell
you anything
yeah and so it's just if we love them
but it's just kind of frustrating
because we never know I mean they're
both 75
uh we want them to enjoy retirement we
don't expect to get the business for
free or anything like that we you know
willing to work with them but that's why
I think settling on a number it's like
what what does the business bring in
what's the top line revenue you have no
idea
no idea I know my wife has if this
wasn't her parents business and someone
said hey you want to take over this
business I won't tell you how much it
makes I won't tell you anything about
what our net profit is but do you want
to give us 50 of the profits forever you
would tell them to kick rocks and pound
sand wouldn't you
exactly yeah and so we're not going to
move forward with this until they're
going to be honest and we're going to
see these numbers on paper not just
hearsay well and even then you may not
want to move forward with it but your
wife wants to take over the catering
business
well yeah I mean she's worked for him
for you know 20 years you know it's hard
work that's different than does she want
to just because it's comfortable and
it's what she knows
do
um but she kind of wants to know
how much she's going to be making you
know and that kind of thing too is she
working there full time right now yeah
yeah yeah well what does she make right
now as a full-time employee she makes
fifty thousand so ideally she's making a
lot more than that if she is an owner of
the business now that's before the split
profits
yeah and that's the only thing we don't
know I mean we don't know if it's going
to be they may be pulling in 60
000. and now we've got to split that and
it's 30.
yeah okay well I would I would tread
lightly carefully with legal
documentation not because we don't trust
them but because we don't want
relationships to get severed in this
process
right okay so I also I would parse this
out you taking over this business is not
their retirement plan
their lack of planning does not
constitute your emergency in this
scenario
okay and so if the plan is hey unless
this goes perfectly and this business
runs perfectly we can't put food on the
table that's a dangerous situation
and so I would make sure that we have
very clear rules on what this is going
to look like because what happens if
there's a down year
right yeah I mean the there's so much
fluctuation with uh with catering in
general and you know you're like covet
was really hard yeah and the thing with
her mom there's a lot of the baking and
decorating and so when she retires she's
gonna have to hire somebody to kind of
fill that role I don't know I think it's
just going to be kind of a strain on the
business to support
yeah you may have to hire outside people
which will be another expense which will
reduce profits it sounds like it's very
messy and sticky especially with the
emotional aspect I'm sure that the fact
that the parents don't have a lot of
retirement and savings as nerve wracking
so then your wife may feel a little bit
of an obligation to continue forward
with this business to help our parents
but I would also challenge you to
consider the option of selling the
business to someone else like
potentially if your wife doesn't want to
keep this specific business maybe she
wants to start her own catering company
from the ground up the parents can still
sell the business to someone else and
then they have that clear boundary that
hard break where they no longer have
their foot in the business they no
longer have control of the finances and
then they could possibly have a little
Nest Egg to move forward with in their
retirement and again you want that in
writing unfortunately we would buy it
from them and they're like well we're
afraid we're going to run out of money
for retirement
so I know it sounds harsh but that's not
your problem
and so you say hey I'm willing to
purchase it outright but we're not going
to do this deal where you just get 50
forever we're not comfortable with that
unless you say you get 50 up until X
number and we call that good
and if you never hit that number that's
a risk they're taking as well
a number of years to do that
all this to say this is messy and it's
given me anxiety and so I would tread
with a lot of caution here and get
everything on paper and even in the
contract you might want to say hey we
have the right to sell this business and
give you half of whatever the sale is
and call that good and if they go well
that's not enough for us well sorry
that's what we agreed to because who
knows okay I don't want your wife stuck
with this because now she's trying to
cover her parents retirement plan
yeah I would also encourage you when you
sit down to have this conversation you
may need to have a third party in the
room like an attorney who can kind of
bring some reality to that conversation
because with it being her parents it
might be easy for them to say hey like
don't cross this boundary like I'm the
parents you're the daughter well they
can bring in a lot of emotion and drama
and manipulation we raised you you owe
us this and you need someone who can be
completely objective and just bring the
facts and say this is what is normal in
a business transition this is what is
expected and it's not personal it's not
feelings but this is this is what is
healthy parties they'll have ways they
can structure it to where it protects
both both of you
okay so and what are you working
full-time outside of this business yeah
I teach yeah so I I work full time and
and you know we're you know I've got a
we've got a 401k and an IRA
um we're on a good pay you know good
plan I think we just kind of need to get
this ironed out yeah well and you guys
being completely dead free house and
everything three years from now is going
to help out this whole situation because
you've got wiggle room and margin in
case the business takes a few years to
get off the ground if she does take it
over
okay
all right well I appreciate so much you
guys is uh wisdom man yeah absolutely
appreciate the call man and I'm going to
send you a copy of Dave's book entree
leadership and this is his playbook for
how he started this business on a card
table in his living room and has now has
grown it to this amazing Empire and I
think it's going to help you guys get
some parameters and boundaries and help
you understand the right way to run a
business because I don't know how this
business has been running we don't know
anything about this business but this
will lay out exactly how to do hiring
and firing and structure pay and a lot
of the leadership principles as well
because she hasn't been in that
leadership role she's been an employee
and so it's a very different side of the
coin there